Hey there listeners. Back in 2017, we ran an episode about the history of Brazil's iconic yellow national soccer jersey. We were reminded of that story during the recent World Cup, and then again on January 8th, as a mob of right-wing rioters attacked the Brazilian capital, many of them, wearing those iconic yellow shirts. Needless to say, the story of the yellow jersey has taken some real twists and turns in recent years, so today we're going to rerun the original story of the Yellow Jersey has taken some real twists and turns in recent years.
听众朋友们好。早在 2017 年，我们曾制作过一期节目，讲述巴西标志性的黄色国家足球队球衣的历史。在最近的世界杯期间，以及在 1 月 8 日右翼暴徒袭击巴西首都时，我们再次想起了这段故事，当时许多人身上都穿着那些标志性的黄色球衣。不用说，黄色球衣的故事近年来经历了一些真正的曲折，所以今天我们要重新播放黄色球衣的最初故事近年来经历的一些真正的曲折。
So today, we're going to rerun that original story about the Jersey's origins, and then producer Emmett Fitzgerald is going to update us on everything that has happened since. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Genio Colasso, Paravilioso, Ingridio, Eceptional! When a Brazilian soccer player scores a goal, the announcer starts slow. And it builds. Until it reaches a glorious crescendo. They do this all over the world now, but it started in Brazil. And there's something particularly triumphant about it there.
所以今天，我们将重新播放关于这件球衣起源的最初故事，然后制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）将为我们更新自那以后发生的一切。这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。Genio Colasso, Paravilioso, Ingridio, Eceptional!（太棒了、美妙绝伦、无与伦比、非同凡响！）当巴西球员进球时，解说员的声音由慢及快。情绪不断高涨。直到达到一个辉煌的高潮。现在他们全世界都在这么做，但它发源于巴西。而且在那里的表现有一种特别凯旋的意味。
That's producer Joe Sykes. That's because soccer means so much to Brazil. How can I explain what soccer means to Brazilians without sounding corny, but I think I'm going to have to sound corny, okay? That's Fernando Duarte, a BBC journalist who wrote a book about Brazilian soccer. Soccer, or football as I call it being British, arrived in Brazil in the late 19th century. At first it was a game played in elite circles and in cities, but poor and working-glass Brazilians struggled to make the game their own. The only time the elites were robbed or deprived of something by the poor people or by the common folk
那是制作人乔·赛克斯（Joe Sykes）。这是因为足球对巴西意味着太多。我该如何向巴西人解释足球意味着什么，而又听起来不那么老土呢？但我猜我不得不听起来很老土，好吧？那是费尔南多·杜 Duarte（Fernando Duarte），一位写过一本关于巴西足球的书的 BBC 记者。足球（用我这个英国人的话来说就是 football）在 19 世纪末传入巴西。起初，它是在精英圈子里和城市中玩的游戏，但贫穷和工人阶级的巴西人努力让这项运动成为他们自己的东西。精英阶层唯一一次被穷人或普通百姓抢劫或剥夺某些东西的时候
is when football seized to be a game for the elites and it became a mass sport. Soccer eventually became so popular and beloved in Brazil that their national team soccer jersey has become as much a national symbol as the country's flag. We're going to see many more people in Brazil wearing the shirt than waving the flag. As a sense of belonging, no matter if you're picking up old sawdust cans on the street or if you're a millionaire, when you wear that shirt, you're just like one of us. Those shirts are extraordinary. They are Sintillating. In fact, I think the word is
就是足球不再是精英的游戏，而变成了大众运动。足球最终在巴西变得如此受欢迎和深受喜爱，以至于他们的国家队球衣已经成为与该国国旗一样重要的国家象征。我们在巴西看到穿这件球衣的人会比挥舞国旗的人多得多。作为一种归属感，不管你是在街上捡旧锯末罐头的人还是百万富翁，当你穿上那件球衣时，你就像我们中的一员。那些球衣非同寻常。它们闪闪发光。事实上，我认为这个词是
Choriscating. That's the Socorita and historian David Goblatt. There are flashes of diamond light coming off of those shirts. The Brazilian soccer shirts are so iconic that non-soccer fans all over the world can often picture them, but for those of you who can't, the shirt is a bright, canary yellow with green trim around the collar and sleeves. They're worn with blue shorts, a pure primary blue. Compared with other soccer jerseys, the uniform is joyful and bold. It seems to capture something essential about Brazil. But it wasn't always this way. In fact, Brazil used to play in plain, unremarkable white shirts. The story of how the uniform changed goes back 70 years to an epic soccer game that Brazilians will never forget.
炫目（Choriscating）。那是社会学家兼历史学家大卫·戈德布拉特（David Goldblatt）。那些球衣上闪烁着钻石般的光芒。巴西足球球衣非常具有标志性，以至于全世界非球迷通常也能想象出它们的模样，但对于你们中那些想象不出来的人来说，球衣是明亮的金丝雀黄，衣领和袖口周围有绿色饰边。它们搭配蓝色的短裤，一种纯正的原生蓝。与其他足球球衣相比，这套队服既欢快又大胆。它似乎捕捉到了巴西的一些本质。但情况并非一直如此。事实上，巴西过去穿着朴素、毫不起眼的白色球衣。关于这套队服如何改变的故事可以追溯到 70 年前的一场巴西人永远不会忘记的史诗级足球赛。
After years of lobbying, the World Cup arrived in Brazil in 1950. At the time, the country was culturally and internationally unknown. This was Brazil's big moment to show the world what it was made of. The 1950 World Cup was understood by the Brazilian population as an opportunity to say to the world, Brazil has arrived. They knew this World Cup was their chance to tell everyone. We have modernised, we have been transformed, we've moved from being an agricultural plantation economy to a new urban industrialised economy and this is our way of showing it. The main symbol of that coming out apart from what was happening on the soccer field was
经过多年的游说，世界杯于 1950 年来到了巴西。当时，该国在文化上和国际上都默默无闻。这是巴西向世界展示其真正实力的重大时刻。1950 年世界杯被巴西民众视为向世界宣告“巴西来了”的机会。他们知道这次世界杯是他们告诉所有人的机会。我们已经现代化了，我们已经转型了，我们已经从一个农业种植园经济体转变为一个新的城市工业化经济体，这就是我们展示这一点的方式。除了足球场上发生的事情之外，这种崭露头角的主要象征是
the stadium named the Maricanar in Rio de Janeiro. It looks like the stadium from outer space. I mean, it is this fabulous flat white concrete oval with amazing flying buttresses. Just like this huge flying saucer that had dropped down in the centre of the city. But done with this sort of incredible sort of modernist elegance. I mean, it was the greatest stadium built since the Colosseum. So they had the stadium, the people were behind them, the government was pushing the tournament whenever possible. Now all they needed was a successful team.
位于里约热内卢的马拉卡纳体育场。它看起来就像来自外太空的体育场。我的意思是，这是一个神话般的扁平白色混凝土椭圆形建筑，带有令人惊叹的飞扶壁。就像一个巨大的飞碟降落在城市中心。但却带有这种不可思议的现代主义优雅。我的意思是，它是自斗兽场以来建造的最大的体育场。所以他们有了体育场，人民支持他们，政府也在尽可能地推动这项赛事。现在他们只需要一支成功的球队。
The expectations were high because of this whole climate, this atmosphere of optimism. In one of their earlier games, Brazil strobe confidently onto the field in our white uniforms and proceeded to demolish Sweden 7-1. Brazil were absolutely fantastic in the opening rounds. They were slaughtering everybody, the scoring goals or over the place. They beat Spain, six one. They also beat Mexico and Yugoslavia. The tournament was going exactly to plan.
由于这种整体氛围、这种乐观的氛围，期望值很高。在他们早期的比赛中，巴西队自信满满地穿着白色队服走上球场，并以 7-1 的比分击溃了瑞典队。巴西队在预赛中绝对棒极了。他们屠杀了所有人，到处进球。他们以六比一击败了西班牙。他们还击败了墨西哥和南斯拉夫。比赛完全按照计划进行。
It was this whole atmosphere of like sporting bliss. And all they had to do is get a draw of your way into the last match. Because of a quirk in the tournament structure, all Brazil had to do to win the World Cup was tie against Uruguay in their final game. Uruguay historically had been a really strong team, even though they're a tiny country almost 50 times smaller than Brazil. But by the time this 1950 World Cup came along,
这就是那种运动狂喜的氛围。他们所要做的就是进入最后一场比赛。由于比赛结构的一个怪癖，巴西队赢得世界杯只需在最后一场比赛中与乌拉圭打平。从历史上看，乌拉圭一直是一支实力非常强劲的球队，尽管他们是一个几乎比巴西小 50 倍的小国。但当这届 1950 年世界杯到来时，
Uruguay was a waning power in soccer, so beating them or at least tying them seemed totally doable, not a problem. Still, Uruguay was no pushover, especially when they were playing against Brazil. Uruguay actually used to be a Brazilian province, so they had this chip on their shoulder about their older, bigger, next door neighbor. The whole thing of being a Uruguayan, going against the odds, fighting against an old colonial power. It spurred them on. Meanwhile, the whole of Rio is now thinking about just one thing, the World Cup Final.
乌拉圭是足球界日渐衰落的力量，所以击败他们或者至少与他们打平似乎完全可行，不是问题。尽管如此，乌拉圭也不是好惹的，尤其是当他们对阵巴西时。乌拉圭实际上曾经是巴西的一个省，所以他们对于自己这个年长、体型更大、隔壁的邻居有一种受迫害妄想。作为一个乌拉圭人，逆境求生，与一个旧殖民帝国抗争的整件事。这激励了他们。与此同时，整个里约现在只想着一件事：世界杯决赛。
There really is mass hysteria about it. Everybody knows about it. Everyone's engaged with it. Everyone wants to go. No one can talk or think about anything else. In Brazil, people like to say that if everybody who claimed to have been in the stadium that afternoon was actually there, the stadium would have needed to be the size of the moon. And it was a big crowd. Some estimate that there were 250,000 screaming fans packed into this flying saucer stadium, which is something like 80,000 people over a capacity. And the players, when they walked out, would just hit with this roll of noise.
那里真的存在群体性歇斯底里。每个人都知道这件事。每个人都参与其中。每个人都想去。没有人能谈论或思考其他任何事情。在巴西，人们喜欢说，如果那天下午声称自己在球场里的每个人真的都在那里，那么球场得有月亮那么大。而且那是一个庞大的观众群。据估计，有 25 万名尖叫的球迷挤在这个飞碟体育场里，这比容量超出了大约 8 万人。当球员们走出来时，他们只被这阵巨大的噪音所冲击。
The place is noisy, it is real custom. But in the first half neither team scores. So the crowd was getting nervous, everybody was getting tense. Then finally Brazil scores a goal. Just after half time, a low shot across the goalkeeper into the bottom corner of the net. And there's just this relief that surges all around the crowd. Even the journalists run on and embrace the players. Because basically everyone there thinks the game is all over. That Brazil has won the World Cup. But then... Uruguay scores.
这个地方很吵闹，真的是习俗。但在上半场，双方都没有得分。所以观众开始紧张，每个人都变得紧张起来。接着巴西终于进球了。半场刚过，一个低平球穿过门将射入球门底角。人群中顿时涌起一阵解脱感。甚至记者们也跑上场拥抱球员。因为基本上那里的每个人都认为比赛已经结束了。巴西赢得了世界杯。但随后……乌拉圭进球了。
About halfway through the second half. The description by whoever was there is that the stadium fell very, very nervous and this nervousness went to the players, almost like they were losing the game. And then comes the moment that everybody will always know right. Our seedest Gigi, one of the Uruguayan wingers, gets the ball and dribbles down the right side
大约在下半场过半时。任何在场的人的描述是，体育场变得非常非常紧张，这种紧张感传到了球员身上，几乎就像他们要输掉比赛一样。然后迎来了每个人永远都会知道的时刻，对吧。吉吉（Ghiggia），乌拉圭边锋之一，拿球并沿着右路带球
toward the goal. And just as he's looking up to pass the ball, he notices that the goalkeeper Barbosa was actually walking to try to anticipate across which meant Barbosa was out of position. So instead of passing the ball, Gigi shoots and scores. All of the reports talk about the most extraordinary silence in the stadium. I'll see the GDO1's said in his book, only three people in the history of the Maracaná, silence that crowd. Frank Sinatra, Pope John Paul II, and me is almost like a graveyard.
朝球门冲去。就在他抬头准备传球时，他注意到门将巴博萨（Barbosa）实际上正向前走试图预判传中，这意味着巴博萨失位了。因此，吉吉没有传球，而是直接起脚射门得分。所有的报道都谈到了球场内最不同寻常的沉默。奥尔西迪·吉吉（Alcides Ghiggia）在他的书中写道，马拉卡纳球场历史上只有三个人让那里的观众陷入沉默。弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）、教皇若望·保禄二世（Pope John Paul II）和我，这几乎就像一个墓地。
Some of the players don't even remember what happened. It was a state of catatonio, something like that. As you have probably guessed by now, Brazil does not manage to get another goal to tie the game in Uruguay, wins. As the game ends, the fans stream out of the stadium and back onto the streets of Rio. It's almost like some kind of apocalypse happening people just when somewhere else. There was this feeling of solitude, this feeling of numbness. And Rio de Janeiro wasn't a party city on the night, on the night of July 16th, 1950.
有些球员甚至不记得发生了什么。这是一种呆滞的状态，诸如此类。正如你现在可能已经猜到的那样，巴西没能在与乌拉圭的比赛中再进一球扳平比分，乌拉圭赢了。随着比赛结束，球迷们涌出体育场，回到里约的街道上。这几乎就像某种世界末日正在发生，人们只是去了别的地方。有一种孤独感，一种麻木感。在 1950 年 7 月 16 日的那个夜晚，里约热内卢不再是一个派对城市。
There was a lot of public crying, there's a lot of hyperbole. One Brazilian playwright caused the defeat Brazil's Hiroshima. All right, well that's just ridiculous. Wish I think is both in bad taste and exaggeration, but people were really blind away. The recriminations came thick and fast, and soon racist accusations started to fly. Barbosa, the guy who played goalkeeper for the Brazilians, was Black. He and two other Black players on the team were scapegoated in the popular press, and Barbosa was even hassled on the street.
有很多人在公开哭泣，有很多夸张的说法。一位巴西剧作家将这场失利称为巴西的“广岛”。好吧，这太荒谬了。我认为这既没有品味又夸张，但人们确实被彻底击垮了。指责接踵而至，不久种族主义的指责开始满天飞。巴博萨，那个为巴西队担任门将的人，是个黑人。他和队中的另外两名黑人球员在主流媒体中成了替罪羊，巴博萨甚至在街上受到骚扰。
His life was made difficult. There's a tragic story he tells later in life of hearing a woman whispering to a child, this is the man who made all Brazil cry. After that, the Brazilian team didn't pick another Black Goldkeeper to start in the World Cup for over 50 years. And this wasn't a coincidence. After that game, Black Goldkeepers were regarded as less reliable than white ones in Brazil,
他的生活变得很艰难。他在晚年讲了一个悲惨的故事，听到一个女人对一个小孩子低声说：“这就是那个让整个巴西哭泣的人。”在那之后，巴西队在 50 多年的时间里没有再挑选另一名黑人门将首发出战世界杯。这并非巧合。在那场比赛之后，黑人门将 在巴西被认为不如白人门将可靠，
which is disgusting. But Barboso wasn't the only focus of Brazilian blame. In fact, everything about Brazilian soccer was scrutinized down to the uniforms the players were wearing. The authorities father the white shirt was cursed, and I think everybody else in Brazil did. And above all, there was a determination never to play in white shirts again. It was pretty unusual for a team to completely transform their uniform. Most countries have played in the same colors since the first world cup back in the early 20th century. But
这太令人作呕了。但巴博萨并不是巴西人指责的唯一焦点。事实上，关于巴西足球的一切都受到了严格审查，甚至包括球员们穿的队服。当局认为白衬衫被诅咒了，我想巴西的其他所有人也这么认为。最重要的是，他们下定决心再也不穿白衬衫了。对于一支球队来说，完全改变他们的队服是相当不寻常的。自从上世纪初第一届世界杯以来，大多数国家一直穿着相同的颜色。但是
the Brazilians decided their uniform was a problem. So in 1953, the Brazilians soccer authorities set up a competition and advertised it in a national newspaper that's distributed all over Brazil. They wanted people to write in with their designs for a new uniform. The contest had only one stipulation. The color of the uniform had to include all the colors of the Brazilian flag. Green, blue, white, and yellow,
巴西人决定他们的队服是个问题。于是在 1953 年，巴西足球当局设立了一场比赛，并在全巴西发行的全国性报纸上进行了广告宣传。他们希望人们写信提交他们对新队服的设计。比赛只有一个规定。队服的颜色必须包含巴西国旗的所有颜色。绿色、蓝色、白色和黄色，
a design that would truly represent Brazil. Hundreds of people entered the contest, including this guy. My name is Aljígor C.S.L. and I'm from Jaguaron, on the board with Uruguay. Aldea Garcia Schley. He was just 19 when he entered the competition, a young man who had grown up in a little town right on the border between Brazil and Uruguay. Schlä wasn't a designer, he was working at a local newspaper as an illustrator. He says when he first heard about the competition, he thought it would be too difficult.
一个真正能代表巴西的设计。数百人参加了比赛，其中包括这个人。我叫阿尔西戈尔·C·S·L（Aljígor C.S.L.），我来自乌拉圭边界的雅瓜朗（Jaguaron）。阿尔代亚·加西亚·施莱（Aldea Garcia Schley）。他参加比赛时年仅 19 岁，是一个在巴西和乌拉圭边界的小镇长大的年轻人。施莱不是设计师，他在当地一家报纸当插画家。他说当他第一次听到这个比赛时，他认为这太难了。
The first impression I had was that Jesus was foolish, that was ridiculous. Primeira impressão que eu tive que estar tava de uma bobagem. Sim, a primeira impressão que eu tinha foi que Jesus foi fulhante, que foi ridiculous. Sim, porque é sempre que tem um team com 4 colars. O que 4 colars no justo do chute era bem difícil, mas, eventualmente, a Shlay se fez que ele poderia usar o uniforme de um uniforme para poder treinar os colars. Ele tentou白ar com a grinsha, um chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de chute de ch spread out the colors. He tried blue shorts with a green shirt, a yellow and green striped shirt with white shorts, a green and yellow striped shirt with blue
我最初的印象是，这太愚蠢了，这太荒谬了。葡萄牙语原声：Primeira impressão que eu tive que estar tava de uma bobagem. Sim, a primeira impressão que eu tinha foi que Jesus foi fulhante, que foi ridiculous. Sim, porque é sempre que tem um team com 4 colars. O que 4 colars no justo do chute era bem difícil, mas, eventualmente, a Shlay se fez que ele poderia usar o uniforme de um uniforme para poder treinar os colars. Ele tentou白ar com a grinsha... 分散这些颜色。他尝试了蓝色短裤搭配绿色衬衫，黄色和绿色相间的衬衫搭配白色短裤，绿色和黄色相间的衬衫搭配蓝色
shorts. He came up with over 200 different designs. Until eventually he had it. Blue shorts, white socks, and a yellow shirt with green trim around the neck and the sleeves. He sent the design off and a few weeks later he looked down at the Ele sentou o desenho e há um pouco de semana. Ele se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima e se olhou na p in the newsroom where I worked, it was like something impossible had just happened. After he won, Schlagotte Bask in the glory of it all for a while. He went to Rio, did an internship with the newspaper that had sponsored the contest, he even lived with the Brazilian players for a few months. But eventually, he returned to his small town and kind of forgot about the shirt for a while. But pretty soon, the shirt was Brazil.
短裤。他设计了 200 多种不同的款式。直到最后他终于成功了。蓝色短裤、白色袜子，以及带有领口和袖口绿色饰边的黄色衬衫。他把设计寄了出去，几周后他低头看了看......葡萄牙语原声：Ele sentou o desenho e há um pouco de semana. Ele se olhou na péssima e se olhou na péssima... 在我工作的编辑室里，这就像刚刚发生了不可能的事情一样。他获胜后，施莱陶醉在这一切的荣耀中一段时间。他去了里约，在赞助比赛的报社实习，他甚至和巴西球员一起住了几个月。但最终，他回到了自己的小镇，把这件球衣忘了一阵子。但很快，这件球衣就成为了巴西。
In 1962, the Brazilians won the World Cup in Chile, and they were wearing Schles uniform. Players like Pele wore the yellow shirt and dazzled the world with their extraordinary skill and beauty. Then color TV comes along, and the whole world can watch Brazil in brand new technical Here's soccer historian David Goblaggan. For me, there's a memory there that I think lots of people have, even if they didn't see it, of dazzle, of brilliance, of amazing, sort of global South sunshine, of flour. Where Brazil had failed in 1950, the following years saw success after success. They won World Cup after World Cup. They yellow shirts becoming as much a hallmark as their intricate footwork and dazzling play.
1962 年，巴西人在智利赢得了世界杯，他们穿着施莱设计的队服。像贝利这样的球员穿着黄色球衣，以他们非凡的球技和美感令世界倾倒。然后彩色电视出现了，全世界都可以在全新的技术中观看巴西队......这里是足球历史学家大卫·戈德布拉格（David Goblaggan）。对我来说，那里有一个记忆，我认为很多人都有，即使他们没有看到，那种耀眼、辉煌、惊人的、南方阳光般的、花朵般的记忆。巴西在 1950 年失败的地方，随后的几年里迎来了接二连三的成功。他们赢了一届又一届世界杯。他们的黄色球衣成为了他们精湛的脚法和耀眼的球风的标志。
Shlays' design became iconic, a symbol of Brazil, full of sun and life. But for Shlays, life wasn't quite living up to the image of Brazil he had created. He started working as a writer in academic. In a 1964, a brutal US-backed military dictatorship took power in a coup. The new military government cracked down on people it considered to be subversive, including academics. Like a lot of other professors and students, Chile was arrested for basically being on the political left. When he got out of jail, he was expelled from his teaching job and was banned from leaving the country. Por cima, mas de qualquer maneira ultralma... Sim, eu estava traumatizando minha vida e meus sonhos,
施莱的设计成为了标志性的存在，一个充满阳光和生命的巴西的象征。但对施莱来说，生活并没有完全达到他所创造的巴西的形象。他开始作为一名作家和学者工作。1964 年，一个残酷的、美国支持的军事独裁政权通过政变夺取了政权。新的军政府严厉打击它认为是颠覆分子的人，包括学者。像许多其他教授和学生一样，施莱因为基本上属于政治左翼而被捕。当他出狱后，他被剥夺了教职，并被禁止离开国家。葡萄牙语原声：Por cima, mas de qualquer maneira ultralma... Sim, eu estava traumatizando minha vida e meus sonhos, nós sofremos muito. E sofremos muito. A dictação foi mais forte há 20 anos... 但是尽管在军政府统治下生活有种种困难，施莱对于写作依然很成功，并且他发展出了一种特殊的......施莱将他的一生用于书写巴西和乌拉圭之间的边界。我是一个心和身体都在巴西与乌拉圭之间分裂的公民。
nós sofremos muito. E sofremos muito. A dictação foi mais forte há 20 anos, mas, despitea as dificuldades de viver entre o maior e o maior de militares, Shlay foi um sucesso para o ritor, e ele developed uma espécie de espacial. Shlay spente seu seu life writing about the border between Brazil and Uruguay. I am a citizen who has a heart and a body divided between Brazil and Uruguay.
（此处音频混淆跳过重复片段）
Shlay was technically born in Brazil, but less than a mile from the border with Uruguay. In fact, when he was a kid, his father helped build a bridge across the river that separates Uruguay from Brazil. I am from the era where the bridge was built. My father went to help build the bridge. So I was being very connected to Uruguay. Shlays experience growing up between two countries and his experiences under military rule have helped shape his feelings about Brazilian nationalism. Even though he designed a shirt that could be considered more patriotic than the Brazilian flag,
施莱严格来说出生在巴西，但距离乌拉圭边界不到一英里。事实上，当他还是个孩子的时候，他的父亲帮忙建造了一座横跨分隔乌拉圭和巴西的河流的桥梁。我来自建造桥梁的时代。我父亲去帮忙建造那座桥。所以我与乌拉圭有着非常深厚的联系。施莱在两个国家之间长大的经历以及他在军事统治下的经历，塑造了他对巴西民族主义的感情。尽管他设计了一件可能被认为比巴西国旗更具爱国主义色彩的球衣，
he's actually very wary of patriotism. It is an idea that I have, it is an idea that I compete with the ones that I have é uma ideia que concorre com aquelas que eu tenho a respeito e isso é uma ideia de competir com as coisas que eu tenho para limitar e limitar e limitar os bordes. Shlay não pode ser um patrioto brasileiro, mas o soccer fan em ele não pode ser muito prato de o brasileiro. O Brasil foi cinco vezes, campeão. Brasil é um campeão de 5 vezes. Brasil é um campeão de 5 vezes.
他实际上对爱国主义非常警惕。葡萄牙语原声：这是我拥有的一个想法，这是一个与我拥有的想法相竞争的想法...... 施莱可能不是一个巴西爱国者，但他心中的足球迷无法不是一个巴西球迷。巴西已经五次成为冠军。巴西是 5 次冠军。巴西是 5 次冠军。
Esse é um sorvete de prédio. É o honor para todos nós, para todos nós. Mas a Lei tem um secret, ou algo que nunca ia te mostrar com pessoas que sabia que ele era o designer de uma famície de chão. A Lei é o ruta de Uruguai. Por muito em Brasile, esse é o plástico, mas não para ele. Nós somos um povo, A gente tem um pouco de comunidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade.
这是一个建筑物的冰淇淋。这是我们所有人的荣耀，对我们所有人来说。但施莱有一个秘密，或者说有些东西他绝不会向那些知道他是著名球衣设计者的人展示。施莱支持乌拉圭。在巴西很长一段时间里，这是个秘密，但对他来说不是。葡萄牙语原声：我们是一个民族，我们有一点共同体意识。我们有一种文化认同。我们有一种文化认同。我们有一种文化认同。
A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade.
（此处音频重复原文块的葡萄牙语旁白）
A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. A gente tem um cultura identidade. culturally connected to both Brazil and Uruguay, but he ultimately had to pick one country's team to root for. So these days, when Brazil plays Uruguay, Shlei, like a lot of other soccer fans, suits up in his favourite jersey, but not the yellow shirt he designed, a sky blue one, the colour of Uruguay. Then he crosses the border from Brazil to Uruguay and finds some quiet bar to watch the game. After break, we get a critical update from Emmett about the rollercoaster the yellow jersey has been on since we first aired that story.
（此处音频重复原文块的葡萄牙语旁白）在文化上与巴西和乌拉圭都有联系，但他最终必须选择一个国家的球队来支持。所以这些天，当巴西对阵乌拉圭时，施莱像许多其他球迷一样，穿上他最喜欢的球衣，但不是他设计的黄色球衣，而是一件天蓝色的，乌拉圭的颜色。然后他跨越从巴西到乌拉圭的边界，找一家安静的酒吧看比赛。休息过后，我们将听到埃米特带来的关于黄色球衣自从我们首次播出那个故事以来所经历的过山车般命运的关键更新。
Okay, so I'm here with producer Emmett Fitzgerald, who is going to give us an update on the state of the Brazilian soccer jersey and what's happened since 2017. Yeah, a lot has happened to the Brazil soccer jersey since we first aired that episode. It was really interesting to me listening back to the story that the designer of the jersey Schley was someone who was really wary of nationalism, especially given what has just happened in Brazil on January 8th. Yeah, and just to recap on January 8th, thousands of far-right nationalists descended on the capital city of Brasilia to protest the inauguration of Lula, Brazil's new president.
好的，我和制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德在一起，他将为我们更新巴西足球球衣的现状以及自 2017 年以来发生的事情。是的，自从我们首次播出那一集以来，巴西足球球衣发生了很多变化。回听这个故事让我觉得很有趣，球衣的设计者施莱是一个对民族主义非常警惕的人，尤其是鉴于 1 月 8 日刚刚在巴西发生的事情。是的，回顾一下，1 月 8 日，数千名极右翼民族主义者涌入首都巴西利亚，抗议巴西新总统卢拉的就职典礼。
Kays and Brazil, as thousands storm the country's capital, protesting October's election results, supporters of far-right former president. The mob attacked Congress, the Supreme Court, and the palace of the president. And it all just felt really, really similar to what happened two years ago in the United States on January 6th. Like a full-on insurrection by right-wing extremists questioning the results of the legitimate presidential election. Yeah, totally it felt disturbingly familiar from an American perspective.
巴西的混乱，数千人冲击该国首都，抗议 10 月份的选举结果，极右翼前总统的支持者。暴徒袭击了国会、最高法院和总统府。这一切感觉真的，真的和两年前美国在 1 月 6 日发生的事情非常相似。就像右翼极端分子对合法总统选举结果提出质疑而发动的全面叛乱。是的，完全如此，从美国人的角度来看，这感觉令人不安地熟悉。
But if you look at videos or images from the Brazilian insurrection, you can't help but notice what the rioters are wearing. The rioters, many dressed in green and yellow, the colors of the Brazilian flag, smashed windows, ransacked offices, even set fire to a carpet inside. Yes, so many of them are wearing the yellow jersey of the National Soccer Team. It isn't just the colors of the flag, like it's the actual soccer team jersey.
但如果你看巴西叛乱的视频或图片，你就会忍不住注意到暴徒穿的是什么。暴徒们许多人穿着绿色和黄色，巴西国旗的颜色，砸碎窗户，洗劫办公室，甚至放火烧毁里面的地毯。是的，他们中有那么多人穿着国家足球队的黄色球衣。这不仅仅是国旗的颜色，就像它是真正的足球队球衣一样。
And I mean, watching these videos, it feels like the jersey has fully become a symbol of the far right, which is a pretty different situation from what we described in the original piece. Yeah, so in the episode that we just played you heard from Brazilian soccer journalist Fernando Duarte, and Fernando describes the Brazilian soccer jersey as this great unifier.
我的意思是，看着这些视频，感觉这件球衣已经完全变成了极右翼的象征，这与我们在原作品中描述的情况截然不同。是的，在我们刚刚播放的那一集里，你听到了巴西足球记者费尔南多·杜 Duarte 的讲述，费尔南多将巴西足球球衣描述为这个伟大的统一力量。
For better or worse it was the symbol of this beautiful game that united what had long been a deeply unequal and divided country. So what happened to the shirt? Like how did it get from there to here? Well, I think we got to start with the 2018 presidential election. Right, what happened after the 2018 presidential election is that one side of the political spectrum claimed the shirt. This is Fernando Duarte again, and he says that after that election, the far right really latched on to the shirt as their own political symbol. He became a symbol of whoever supported
不管好坏，它是这项美丽运动的象征，团结了一个长期以来极度不平等和分裂的国家。那么这件球衣怎么了？它是怎么从那个时候变成现在的样子的？嗯，我认为我们必须从 2018 年的总统大选开始说起。没错，2018 年总统大选之后发生的事情是，政治光谱的一端声称拥有这件球衣。这是费尔南多·杜 Duarte 再次发言，他说那次选举后，极右翼真正将这件球衣作为他们自己的政治象征紧紧抓住。他成为了支持
the far right president, Jair Bolsonaro. He's known as Brazil's Donald Trump, an anti-establishment politician who promises to drain the swamp and crack down on crime. This is CNN coverage from Election Night in 2018 when Jair Bolsonaro was elected. And if you look in videos of crowds on that election, coverage from election night in 2018 when Jair Bolsonaro was elected. And if you look in videos of crowds on that election,
极右翼总统雅伊尔·博索纳罗（Jair Bolsonaro）的人的象征。他被称为巴西的唐纳德·特朗普，一个承诺排干沼泽并打击犯罪的反建制政治家。这是 CNN 对 2018 年大选之夜雅伊尔·博索纳罗当选时的报道。如果你看那次选举中人群的视频，2018 年大选之夜雅伊尔·博索纳罗当选时的报道。如果你看那次选举中人群的视频，
that you'll see a lot of Brazilian flags. And you will see a lot of people wearing the colors of the Brazilian flag, yellow and green. Wearing national symbols, national colors, yellow and green, became something of a badge of identification of the president's supporters. And obviously, what is more yellow in green? What is more representatives of Brazil as a nation than the national team share? Now I want to be really clear that the roots of this connection between the Jersey and the far right go back before Bolsonaro.
你会看到很多巴西国旗。你会看到很多人穿着巴西国旗的颜色，黄色和绿色。佩戴国家象征、国家颜色、黄色和绿色，在某种程度上成为了总统支持者的身份徽章。显然，还有什么比黄色和绿色更具代表性？还有什么比国家队球衣更能代表巴西这个国家呢？现在我想明确指出，球衣与极右翼之间这种联系的根源可以追溯到博索纳罗之前。
In the 60s and 70s and 80s, the military dictatorship in Brazil used the success of the national team, wearing those yellow jerseys on the pitch, to cultivate a sense of nationalism and support for the regime. And even more recently, the far right adopted the yellow and green during the impeachment of former president Dilma Rousseff in 2016. But when Bolsonaro gets into power, this whole thing really escalates in part because he starts to wear the jersey himself. Intentionally, it wasn't an accident. The president intentionally simulated wearing the national team shirt as a sign of true patriotism, of true love to the nation, and obviously
在 60 年代、70 年代和 80 年代，巴西的军事独裁政权利用国家队在球场上穿着黄色球衣的成功，来培养民族主义意识和对政权的支持。更近一点，极右翼在 2016 年前总统迪尔玛·罗塞夫（Dilma Rousseff）弹劾期间也采用了黄绿色。但当博索纳罗上台后，这一切真的升级了，部分原因是他开始自己穿这件球衣。这是刻意为之，并非偶然。总统故意穿上国家队球衣，以此作为真正爱国主义、对国家真挚爱意、以及显然
love to the nation. And the small print was basically support for his agenda. And as you can imagine, this created a real dilemma for a lot of soccer fans in Brazil who were used to wearing that jersey. I always joke that I look great in the yellow as well. So it was always something that I enjoyed doing. This is Julia Belastrindaji. She's a sports journalist from Brazil who's currently getting a PhD in the UK.
对国家热爱的标志。而小字背后的含义基本上是对他议程的支持。正如你可以想象的那样，这给巴西许多习惯于穿那件球衣的球迷带来了真正的困境。我总是开玩笑说我也很适合穿黄色。所以我一直很享受这样做。这是朱莉娅·贝拉斯特林达吉（Julia Belastrindaji）。她是一名来自巴西的体育记者，目前正在英国攻读博士学位。
She says that growing up, she always wore the yellow shirt, especially during World Cups. But she stopped during the Bolsonaro presidency because she didn't want to send the wrong signals. For me, it was kind of okay, I don't want to be seen as something that I'm not. I don't want to be seen as something that I'm not. I don't want to be seen as Bolsonaro. I mean, not to take the Trump analogy too much further, but it feels like a kind of like the red hat thing. Like there's a piece of clothing that for all intents and purposes,
她说在成长过程中，她总是穿黄色球衣，尤其是在世界杯期间。但在博索纳罗总统任期内她停止了，因为她不想发出错误的信号。对她来说，这有点像，好吧，我不想被视为某种我不是的人。我不想被视为博索纳罗的支持者。我的意思是，虽然不想把特朗普的比喻推得太远，但感觉这有点像红帽子效应。就像有一件衣服，从各方面来看，
it's pretty neutral, immediately became an identifier of your political beliefs. Yeah, I think it is a lot like that, except, you know, instead of a sort of random piece of clothing, like a red hat, it's like the most famous and beloved piece of clothing in the country. Totally. You know, I think for the past four years, for a lot of Brazilians, it's felt as though this famous yellow jersey has been symbolically hijacked by the far right. But there were two events this past year that really started to turn things around. And the first was that Bolsonaro lost the presidential election to Luis and Naseo Lula de Silva, better known as just Lula. He was the former president of Brazil and a champion
它原本相当中立，却立刻成为了你政治信仰的标志。是的，我认为它非常相似，只不过，你知道，它不是像红帽子那样随机的一件衣服，而是该国最著名、最受喜爱的衣服。完全同意。你知道，我认为在过去四年里，对许多巴西人来说，感觉这件著名的黄色球衣在象征意义上被极右翼劫持了。但过去一年发生的两件事真正开始扭转局面。首先是博索纳罗在总统选举中输给了路易斯·伊纳西奥·卢拉·达席尔瓦（Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva），也就是人们熟知的卢拉。他是巴西前总统，也是
of the Brazilian left, the Brazilian labor movement. And when he wins, Lula immediately makes a point of trying to reclaim the Jersey. He posted a lot of pictures wearing the Jersey after the election. Like whenever Brazil would play, he would post pictures of him wearing the Jersey. Just after the election, Lula was quoted saying, we can't be ashamed of wearing our green and yellow shirt. It doesn't belong to one particular candidate. It doesn't belong to one particular candidate. It doesn't belong to one particular party. Green and yellow are the colors of 213 million citizens who love this country. So this reclamation is like overt. It isn't like subtle at all.
巴西左翼和巴西劳工运动的冠军。当他获胜时，卢拉立即刻意试图夺回这件球衣。他在选举后发布了许多穿这件球衣的照片。就像每当巴西队比赛时，他都会发布自己穿着这件球衣的照片。就在选举结束后，卢拉被引用说过：“我们不能为穿上我们的绿黄球衣感到羞耻。它不属于某个特定的候选人。它不属于某个特定的政党。绿色和黄色是热爱这个国家的 2.13 亿公民的颜色。”所以这种夺回是公开的。一点也不微妙。
Like he's really speaking to the issue. Yeah, it was this really intentional effort to sort of neutralize the jersey to make it for everyone again. And it was all happening in advance of event number two, which is the World Cup. Right. So we just had the World Cup Congrats to our Argentinian colleague, Martin, who was very invested in the series. Yes. Congrats, Martin. And you know, Argentina's great rivals, Brazil, ended up bowing out pretty early with the disappointing loss to Croatia But in the early stages of the tournament they really were performing very well And you know going into the tournament a lot of people in the left had kind of abandoned the national team, in part because of the associations with the jersey, but also because
就像他真的在谈论这个问题。是的，这是一次非常刻意的努力，旨在使球衣中立化，让它再次属于每个人。这一切都发生在事件二（世界杯）之前。没错。所以我们刚刚经历了世界杯。恭喜我们的阿根廷同事马丁（Martin），他非常投入这个系列。是的。恭喜马丁。你知道，阿根廷的伟大死敌巴西队，最终在输给克罗地亚后不久便黯然出局。但在锦标赛的早期阶段，他们的表现确实非常好。你知道，在进入锦标赛时，左翼的许多人已经抛弃了国家队，部分是因为与球衣的联系，但也因为
a lot of the players were big Bolsonaro supporters, particularly the star Namar. But during those early games, President Alex Lula was very publicly watching and sharing the team on. He was celebrating. He was posting videos watching the game, celebrating the goals. Always with the jersey even, the people who are watching with him wearing suits and, you know, politicians. He always feels like he has to show he is a man of the people and a man of the people in Brazil. What? What's going to support the national team. Right. You can't be a man of the people in Brazil
许多球员都是博索纳罗的大力支持者，尤其是球星内马尔。但在早期的比赛中，卢拉总统非常公开地观看并为球队加油。他在庆祝。他发布了观看比赛、庆祝进球的视频。甚至总是穿着球衣，和他一起观看的人也穿着西装，你知道，还有政治家。他总是觉得自己必须表现得自己是一个贴近民众的人，而作为巴西的贴近民众的人。什么？怎么能不支持国家队呢？没错。在巴西，你不可能成为一个贴近民众的人
and not support the national team. So how well did this work, this sort of intentional reclamation? Did Brazilian soccer fans start embracing the jersey again without necessarily signaling their political leanings? Yeah, I think for a while there was a feeling like it was working. I think for a while there was a feeling like it was working. The timing of Louis election with Brazil's play at the World Cup at Gave, this feeling of a sort of symbolic reset during those early games when Brazil was destroying teams like South Korea and doing their somba dances
却不支持国家队。那么这种刻意的夺回效果如何？巴西球迷是否开始再次拥抱这件球衣，而不一定发出他们的政治倾向信号？是的，我认为有一段时间感觉它正在起作用。我认为有一段时间感觉它正在起作用。卢拉当选的时机与巴西在世界杯上的比赛相吻合，在巴西队以大比分击败韩国队并在进球后身穿黄色球衣跳桑巴舞的那些早期比赛中，带来了一种象征性重置的感觉。
after every goal in the yellow jersey. I think a lot of people got excited and felt sort of like things were back to normal, including Fernando. The Korea game I was watching, I got so excited, I bought a new shirt. You did? Yeah. I don't know, I just got really excited.
我认为很多人都很兴奋，感觉事情恢复了正常，包括费尔南多。韩国那场比赛我在看，我太兴奋了，我买了一件新球衣。你买了？是的。我不知道，我只是太兴奋了。
I said, well, maybe something to buy a shirt again. Maybe when I go running, I'm going to wear it again. It was, as a football fan, I was really, really, really enchanted by the brand of football that they played. And it's the shirt of my country. I think I mean, title to wear it as a Brazilian. So this interview that I did with Fernando happened while the World Cup was still going on. And I think at that point, he and a lot of people were feeling cautiously optimistic, you know, about the team, about the country, about the Jersey. It felt like for the
我说，好吧，也许是时候再次买一件球衣了。也许当我跑步时，我会再次穿上它。作为一名足球迷，我真的、真的、真的被他们踢球的风格所陶醉。这是我国家的球衣。我认为作为一个巴西人，我有权穿它。所以我和费尔南多的这次采访发生在世界杯还在进行的时候。我想在那时，他和许多人对球队、对国家、对球衣都感到谨慎的乐观。感觉
first time in a while, he could maybe wear a yellow jersey out in the world when he goes for his run and not feel like that was going to identify him as a Bolsonaro supporter. And you know, that was kind of the note that we were originally going to end this update on. Yeah, yeah. And then, you know, right around that time, we were wrapping up this January 8th, right? It's happened. Right.
有一段时间以来，他第一次可以穿着黄色球衣去跑步，而不会觉得自己会被当作博索纳罗的支持者。你知道，这原本是我们最初打算用来结束这次更新的基调。是的，是的。然后，你知道，就在那个时候，我们正在完成这个 1 月 8 日的事件发生了。没错。
And obviously, that's like a huge story that is way more important than the story of the Jersey. And there's so many different angles that we're not going to get into. But for the purposes of this episode, I wanted to call Fernando back just to sort of check in with him and see how he was feeling about the jersey and about everything that was going on. Well, what a difference a couple of weeks make, we thought that after the World Cup there will be some, be some reconciliation. No, I think the situation is actually worse now than he was before the World Cup. I think that the situation is actually worse now than he was before the welcome. Fernando says that he certainly is not going to be wearing that new yellow jersey that he
显然，这是一个比球衣故事重要得多的宏大故事。这里有许多我们不会深入探讨的不同角度。但为了本集的需要，我想给费尔南多回个电话，只是为了和交流一下，看看他对球衣和正在发生的一切有何感受。好吧，几周的时间带来了多大的不同，我们以为世界杯后会有一些和解。不，我认为现在的局势实际上比世界杯前还要糟糕。我认为现在的局势实际上比世界杯前还要糟糕。费尔南多说，他当然不会在近期穿上他买的那件新黄色球衣。它要放回衣橱里了。我认为很多人都会因为发生的事情而避免被看到穿任何黄色的衬衫。是的，我想这说得通。我问费尔南多他认为球衣接下来会发生什么。我的意思是，我老实说对他的回答感到非常惊讶。
bought anytime soon. It's going back in the closet. I think a lot of people will refrain from being seen in any other shirt because of what happened. Yeah, I guess that makes sense. I asked Fernando what he thought was gonna happen next with the jersey. And I mean, I honestly was pretty surprised by his answer.
短期内根本不会买。它又得被塞回衣柜里了。我觉得很多人会因为发生过的事而不敢再穿别的衬衫露面了。是的，我猜这说得通。我问费尔南多他觉得这件球衣接下来会怎么样。说实话，他的回答让我挺意外的。
I mean, he, first of all, he doesn't know. He has no idea what's gonna happen, but he says it's conceivable that the country could abandon the yellow jersey. Maybe this is the point where we depart from the yellow one. I think it's difficult to say now, oh, yes, definitely, something's gonna change. But clearly, something has to happen
我的意思是，首先，他并不知道。他完全不知道会发生什么，但他认为这个国家有可能会放弃黄色球衣。也许这就是我们告别黄色球衣的时刻。我认为现在很难说，哦，是的，肯定的，会有所改变。但很显然，有些事情必须发生
in regards to this association with the far right. Whoa. I mean, is that something that you think could actually happen? Well, I mean, even before the World Cup, there was some talk of turning away from the yellow jersey from people on the left who felt that it was just too far gone as a symbol. That movement always felt like a long shop. And now, after January 8th, Fernando is not so sure. He's not totally ridiculous to think they might change the color of the shirt?
关于与极右翼的这种联系。哇。我的意思是，你认为这真的会发生吗？嗯，我的意思是，甚至在世界杯之前，左翼人士就曾讨论过放弃黄色球衣，他们觉得作为一个象征，它已经变得太极端了。这种运动一直感觉像是奢望。而现在，在1月8日之后，费尔南多也不太确定了。认为他们可能会改变球衣颜色的想法并不是完全荒谬的？
There are rumors in Brazil that the Brazilian football Confederation and Nike are to discuss what to do. Because clearly the product is tarnished, right? Imagine if you're Nike, you're paying gazillions of dollars for the right to produce something that now has got a bad reputation. Well, a bad reputation for some. It's really fascinating. I mean, if they were to move away from the yellow jersey, isn't that just kind of like letting one side win this debate, you know, like it just feels like a sad outcome. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I get that. I feel kind of similarly, I think. And I think, I think
巴西有传言称，巴西足协和耐克将讨论该如何应对。因为显然这个产品已经被玷污了，对吧？想象一下，如果你是耐克，你花了大笔大笔的钱来购买生产某种现在名誉扫地的产品的权利。好吧，对于某些人来说确实名誉扫地。这真的很迷人。我的意思是，如果他们放弃黄色球衣，不就像是让其中一方赢得了这场辩论吗，你知道的，这感觉就像是一个悲伤的结果。是的，是的。我的意思是，我明白。我想我也有一种类似的感觉。而且我认为，我认为
Fernando feels that way too. Honestly, he seemed, he seemed pretty unsure of what he thinks should happen next. And I get it. I mean, I think if you're a Brazilian soccer fan who doesn't support Bolsonaro or, or, or, who certainly doesn't support the insurrection, I don't know if there's a great solution here. So if they were to change the jersey, what do you think they would change it to? Well, there are a few options. Brazil has an alternate blue kit
费尔南多也是这么想的。老实说，他似乎，他似乎对接下来应该发生什么感到非常不确定。我能理解。我的意思是，如果你是一个不支持博索纳罗，或者不支持叛乱的巴西足球迷，我不知道这里是否有绝佳的解决方案。所以如果他们要换球衣，你认为他们会换成什么？嗯，有几种选择。巴西有一套备用的蓝色球衣
that they've been wearing for years. It looks pretty nice. And then they could always go back to white. You know what? White is the color of peace. And it's a New Year's tradition in Brazil to wear white underwear or white gloves if you want peace in the New Year.
他们已经穿了很多年了。看起来挺不错的。然后他们随时可以穿回白色。你知道吗？白色是和平的象征。在巴西，新年穿白色内衣或白色手套是一个传统，如果你想在新的一年里祈求和平的话。
So maybe this is a way to kind of like wish for something different. Wow, that would really bring it all full circle. Yeah, I don't know how likely that is given the history. I mean, I think, you know, if I had to say, I think the most likely outcome is probably that the yellow jersey continues and people just keep fighting about what it means. But there's really no doubt that real damage has been done to the Jersey as this symbol of Brazilian unity. You have to watch the space, but clearly something happened, you Well, thank you for that update Emmett, and it's been really fascinating to hear from
所以这也许是一种祈求不同事物的方式。哇，那真的会让一切闭环。是的，考虑到这段历史，我不知道发生的可能性有多大。我的意思是，如果我必须说，我认为最有可能的结果可能是黄色球衣继续存在，而人们继续为它的含义争论不休。但毫无疑问，作为巴西团结象征的球衣确实受到了真正的损害。你必须密切关注事态发展，但显然有些事情发生了，嗯，谢谢你的最新消息，埃米特，听到
Fernando again and all the people that are affected by this, so I appreciate it. Yeah, thank you, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joe Sykes and Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Shreve Usif and Martín González, music by Swan Real and Melodium. English Voice Over by Nea Araúgio. We like to thank Alex Bellos for his help. Alex was the first English journalist to write about this story and helped point us in the right direction.
再次听到费尔南多以及所有受此影响的人的心声，真的非常引人入胜，所以我很感激。是的，谢谢你，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由乔·赛克斯和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，什里·乌西夫和马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔和梅洛迪姆创作。英文配音由内亚·阿劳霍完成。我们要感谢亚历克斯·贝洛斯的帮助。亚历克斯是第一位报道这个故事的英国记者，并帮助我们指明了正确的方向。
Junior Mazza and Famiu Arnalde also fixed everything up for us in Brazil and translated our interview with Shlei. FAMIO are on Nalde, also fixed everything up for us in Brazil, and translated our interview wishlay. The rest of the 99 PI team includes senior editor Jalini Hall, digital director Kurt Colstad, Vivian Le, Christopher Johnson, Chris Barube, Lashmodon, Jason De Leon, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. And now TikTok, our first TikTok video story produced by the insanely talented talent
儒尼奥尔·马扎和法米乌·阿尔纳尔德也在巴西为我们安排好了一切，并翻译了我们对施莱的采访。法米乌·阿尔纳尔德也在巴西为我们安排好了一切，并翻译了我们对施莱的采访。99 PI团队的其他成员包括高级编辑贾利尼·霍尔、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯塔德、薇薇安·勒、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、克里斯·巴鲁比、拉什莫登、杰森·德莱昂、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼里。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入有关该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI org）。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。现在还有TikTok，我们的第一个TikTok视频故事由才华横溢的天才制作
Stradley premiered today. Please check it out. You can find links to other literature shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. work. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
斯特拉德利今天首播。请务必查看。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他文学节目的链接，以及99PI的每一期往期节目。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。